c'est vrai que tout à l'heure plusieurs
mots sont utilisés étrangers en
situation légale et migration migrants
réfugiés clandestins
tout ça ce sont des mots mais moi
j'aimerais que 30 secondes l'on revienne
à une réalité sur le terrain
il ya des hommes et des femmes et c'est
jamais écrit sur leur front et la
puissance publique demande à d'autres
angles à d'autres femmes
les policiers les gendarmes un moment
donné d'être en contact avec cette
réalité très complexe et j'aimerais
qu'on laisse à lui que notre parti salue
ces hommes et ces femmes qui
effectivement font un travail ingrat
font un travail ingrat parce que vous
avez vu que toutes les caméras sont
systématiquement pointés sur eux et que
depuis que manuel valls a inventé cette
magnifique plateforme de la dénonciation
sur internet tous les jours ça croule de
mails de gens qui trouvent que nos
policiers et nos gendarmes sont racistes
l'autre difficulté c'est qu'une fois
l'interpellation était fait qu'on essaye
de trouver le statut c'est compliqué
parce qu'il ya les statuts puis à tous
les faux papiers qui vont avec
on essaie dé mener 5-2 démener ça ne
monte une procédure longue complexe qui
prend beaucoup de temps
pendant qu'on s'occupe de ça on s'occupe
pas des victimes d'autres actes de
délinquance et là encore dans un
commissariat
c'est toujours compliqué de vivre cette
situation on arrive à la présentation
aux juges ont hélas moment formidable on
sait que à l'issue d'une longue
procédure de garde à vue 80 % des
individus sont remis dehors c'est pour
les chiffres la seine-saint-denis 4 un
penseur qui ont dit vous inquiétez pas
nous savons bien que votre situation est
complètement illégal et un moment donné
nous vous demanderons gentiment de
revenir nous voir pour que leur parti
est chez vous on peut rien
malheureusement on pourrait
malheureusement larmes pour notre
mouvement
il n'y a qu'un endroit où on c'est
humainement mais efficacement organiser
le retour c'est le centre de rétention
administratif donc oui il faut choisir
il faut choisir la voie administrative
avec bien sûr tous les contre-pouvoirs
humains pour que nous mettions en place
une procédure lice
yves lé clair humaine en donnant les
moyens nos centres de rétention
adminstrative de faire leur travail et
qu'on arrête l'angélisme de notre petite
durée de 45 jours
alors que l'angleterre durée illimitée
l'allemagne 18 - quand notre mouvement
aujourd'hui dit que six mois peuvent
suffire à l'administration pour mettre
en place les moyens administratifs
normaux pour faire que les individus
repartent
oui ça n'est pas attentatoire aux
libertés publiques
c'est un bon outil normale et contrôlée
surtout que ça permettra aussi certaines
fois de recadrer on parlait de politique
internationale et il faut bien pâle
s'est fait parler d'eux et ça a été
évoqué de ces fameux laissez passer
consulaires où on voit bien que d'un
pays à l'autre
moi j'ai eu un haut fonctionnaire et
hier qui bien évidemment où j'ai vu la
pression ministériel depuis ce matin
fait en sorte qu'ils aient personne au
ministère de l'intérieur dans la salle
me disaient que vous avez des pays qui
sont à 10 % seulement
d'ailleurs pour d'accorder le nombre de
laisser passer consulaire donc soyons
clairs sortons de cette jungle sans
mauvais jeu de mots en se renvoyant vers
calais juridique ou poney ou les
policiers les gendarmes n'y prenne ne
comprennent rien font du sale boulot
vécu comme tel sans aucune efficacité
merci merci à toi brune